these cats are moving across continents
vets have been preparing for their move
from South Africa to India for months
the cheaters are being taken to India to
help the country repopulate
this follows the extinction of the
Asiatic cheaters in India in the 1940s
those who've been monitoring the
progress say the animals will be safe
and will quickly adopt to their new
environments basically a cheetah have
been in Decline for the past 13 000
years South Africa is the first country
to reverse the decline of wild cheetah
populations and our meta population has
grown from 217 to 520 in the last 12
years so we know in a position to export
wild cheaters to other countries
South Africa and India signed an
agreement to introduce dozens of the
animals over the next decades
India also received eight cheaters from
Namibia last year
for South Africa and India of course
these the mother population comes up you
can have a genetic flow and exchange of
animals which is good for for the long
term
perspective from the species
conservation
everyone in this resolve is confident
and also nostalgic
it's a little bit Bittersweet and you've
definitely got to know each individual
cat well over the last seven months so
I'm relieved that we don't have to check
them every day anymore and feed them
maybe three days but um definitely I
would say that we're going to see them
go one two three these creatures will
soon be starting their new life A Long
Way From Home
their caregivers hope they will thrive
in their new environment
Catherine soy Al Jazeera